y
[Música]
en bolivia luis arce candidato del más
sería el ganador de las elecciones
presidenciales en un sondeos a boca de
urna con el 52.4 por ciento de los votos
frente al 30 y 1.5 por ciento de su
principal rival carlos meza la
presidenta interina ya línea les pidió
esperar resultados oficiales ya felicitó
a los virtuales ganadores
el gobierno de chile condenó la
violencia durante las protestas que
conmemoraron el primer aniversario del
estallido social en ese país a una
semana del referendo que pretende
cambiar la constitución miles de
personas se reunieron en santiago en una
manifestación empañada con algunos
incidentes violentos entre ellos saqueos
y la quema de dos iglesias
en france 24 comenzamos una nueva serie
sobre el voto latino en eeuu a dos
semanas de las elecciones presidenciales
la comunidad hispana es la primera
minoría en ese país y un número récord
de votantes participarán en estos
comicios del 3 de noviembre
convirtiéndose en un electorado clave
para las campañas de trump y joe bailan
muy buenas noches gracias por continuar
con nosotros en france 24 se hablan con
gusto saludarlos comenzamos a este
informativo en bolivia donde se siguen
esperando los resultados oficiales de
las elecciones presidenciales del
domingo 18 de octubre sin embargo según
conteos no oficiales luís arce el
partido movimiento al socialismo más
sería el ganador de estos comicios
obtenían un 52.4 por ciento sobre su
principal rival carlos meza quien habría
obtenido un 31.5 por ciento
arze quien es el delfín político del ex
presidente evo morales celebró la
victoria que deberá ser confirmada por
el órgano electoral en los próximos días
a través de su cuenta de twitter la
presidenta interina del país anime años
afirmó que aún no existe un completo
cómputo oficial pero por los datos con
los que cuentan dio por ganadores al
besarse y su fórmula vicepresidencial
además les pidió gobernar pensando en
bolivia y en la democracia escuchemos lo
que fueron parte de estas declaraciones
de luís arce
vamos a gobernar para todos los
gobiernos
vamos a construir un gobierno
internacional
vamos a construir la unidad
y yo creo que hoy
una dirección
ha sido para el pueblo lo que es el
pueblo
entre tantos de su exilio en argentina
el ex presidente o morales aseguró que
su partido el más ganó las elecciones y
que luís arse será el nuevo presidente
veamos todos los datos conocidos la
tabla sede a la que se ha producido una
victoria de 'la vuelta al socialismo
instrumento político por las obras de
los pueblos recuperamos la patria
recuperaremos la estabilidad y el
progreso
recuperaremos la paz
quieres a la denuncia de otro antepasado
volveremos millones y devolveremos la
libertad y la vida al pueblo brillan
muchas gracias
para analizar el panorama político de
bolivia estamos en contacto con maría
teresa zegada y ya es analista política
socióloga y politóloga maría tereza buen
día gracias por estar aquí con nosotros
en france 24 sigue en falta el resultado
oficial visar se es el virtual ganador
de estas elecciones presidenciales le
pregunto cómo se puede entender ese
apoyo al movimiento al socialismo un año
después de la renuncia de evo morales
bueno son varias cosas no bueno primero
hay que esperar el resultado oficial
evidentemente pero estos datos que
tenemos ya nos muestra una tendencia
bastante clara y probablemente
irreversible del tiempo en primera
vuelta lo que llama la atención es la
distancia entre los datos que tenían las
encuestas que era aproximadamente 30 por
ciento para el más y este dato que ya es
mucho más contundente sin embargo de por
qué explica este retorno yo creo que en
realidad el modelo del del político del
movimiento al socialismo no se agotó lo
que se agotó en realidad fue esta forma
de gestión política que imprimió el ex
presidente morales a sus últimos años de
gobierno y que el cuyo hecho más
importante fue esta esta manipulación
estas irregularidades en el acto
electoral lo que ahora tenemos es más
bien yo creo un ordenamiento del
escenario político las autoridades
tendrán finalmente legalidad y
legitimidad y otro elemento que explica
está este este giro en el voto este esta
recuperación digamos del proyecto del
movimiento al socialismo como
organización son los
casi 11 años de perdón 11 meses de
gobierno interino un gobierno que no
sólo fue golpeado por la postura de nia
sino además bueno fue un gobierno
bastante inconsistente entonces eso ha
significado también una reacción de la
población frente a esa posibilidad del
retorno de ciertos debates a la mujer
y perdón si no la interrumpo porque no
quiero que se me quede por fuera una
pregunta muy importante y es que cuáles
serán los principales desafíos para este
gobierno le pido que sea lo más breve
posible claro que sí el principal
desafío va a ser
enfrentar las urgencias sanitarias y
económicas del país otro desafío
importante más de la necesidad de
generar acuerdos políticos en un
escenario donde ellos tienen una mayoría
absolutamente importante quizás ha sido
una señal una enseñanza en la democracia
mostrarles que aquí por el camino de los
acuerdos y no por el camino de la
imposición y finalmente a otro desafío
importante va a ser evidentemente una
recomposición del propio movimiento al
socialismo una democratización de sus
estructuras y una renovación profunda
como organización social maría teresa
buen día gracias por estar aquí con
nosotros en france 24 gracias por su
tiempo decenas de miles de manifestantes
se movilizaron en las calles de santiago
el domingo para al cumplirse el primer
aniversario el estallido social contra
la desigualdad en ese país los
manifestantes renovaron los reclamos por
una reforma de la constitución
semana del referéndum que decidirá si se
modifica la carta magna- el cierre de la
jornada estuvo marcado por algunos
incidentes como la quema de dos iglesias
y la violencia y la violenta represión
policial veamos más en el siguiente
informe
[Aplausos]
las llamas invaden la torre de esta
iglesia y los bomberos luchan en vano
para apagar el fuego fue una de las
imágenes del final de la jornada de
protestas en santiago decenas de miles
de ciudadanos se movilizaron al
cumplirse un año del estallido social
contra la desigualdad en el país las
manifestaciones se desarrollaron de
forma pacífica hasta el final del día
cuando se desataron algunos episodios de
violencia y saqueos los carabineros
respondieron con gases lacrimógenos y
cañones de agua
las pensiones que es lo que estamos
luchando llevamos más de un año luchando
por las pensiones sueldos estudio todo
cachai pero yo por mi sector yo no veo
ningún cambio las protestas de 2019
iniciaron por un alza en la tarifa del
metro de santiago pero rápidamente se
convirtieron en un reclamo más amplio
por mejor acceso a la salud y de
educación cambios en el sistema de
pensiones y sobre todo una reforma de la
constitución de carácter neoliberal
heredada de la dictadura de augusto
pinochet la violenta respuesta policial
a esas movilizaciones dejó más de 30
muertos y miles de heridos
el llamado un referendo constitucional y
sobre todo la pandemia de kobe 19
hicieron mermar las protestas pero éstas
renovaron su fuerza a una semana del
plebiscito
y vamos a votar
las unas a orinar el próximo fin de
semana y será la oportunidad para que
los manifestantes se expresen
democráticamente contra la constitución
considerada por ellos como la base de
las desigualdades en el país
vamos precisamente a santiago con
nuestra corresponsal patricia luna
patricia buenos días cuál es el balance
después de esta manifestación que fue
pacífica la mayor parte del tiempo
buenos días estamos exactamente en el
lugar que ayer estaba lleno de gente en
una jornada maratoniana que comenzó a
las 10 de la mañana y se extendió hasta
las 12 de la noche o más donde seguía
habiendo gente en este mismo lugar las
autoridades dieron hoy un balance hay
580 detenidos en todo el país
287 de ellos en la región metropolitana
donde nos encontramos un total de 107
actos o incidentes violentos también el
subsecretario de interior juan galli
confirmó la muerte de una persona en la
población de la victoria en hechos que
aún se investigan si tendría que ver el
actuar de carabineros en esa situación
ahora dos iglesias fueron quemadas por
encapuchados en el centro de la capital
chilena le pregunto si se sabe por qué
lo hicieron
bueno esa es la pregunta un poco del
millón pero es cierto que las iglesias
han sido objeto de ataque durante el
estallido social en varias ocasiones de
hecho las dos iglesias habían sido
atacadas se trata de la iglesia de
carabineros que ya había sido una
iglesia que pertenece a la institución a
la policía chilena ya había sido quemada
en enero de este mismo año y también la
iglesia cuya cúpula cayó la iglesia de
la asunción que se encuentra a escasos
metros de donde nos encontramos ahora
también había sido vandalizada es verdad
que en el país existe mucha rabia contra
los escándalos de pedofilia que hicieron
los titulares mundiales hace unos años y
que es un también un icono un reflejo de
un poder estatal y también se suele
atacar contra este tipo de institución o
con este tipo de contra las iglesias que
han sido objeto de ataques vandálicos en
el país se registraron también saqueos y
otros incidentes violentos
patricia gracias por la información
feliz día en francia el gobierno anunció
este lunes que las autoridades
comenzaron operativos policiales contra
decenas de personas
por haber colgado mensajes de odio en
internet que justificaban el ataque
contra el profesor samuel para ti ha
asesinado el viernes en una localidad a
las afueras de parís
libertad de expresión y libertad para
enseñar es lo que algunos manifestantes
gritan en medio de las calles de parís
en memoria de samuel patín un profesor
que fue asesinado cuando regresaba a
casa luego de su jornada en una escuela
de una localidad al norte de la capital
francesa algunos llevaron carteles que
decían yo soy profesor y muchos se
unieron para demostrar su apoyo y
solidaridad tenemos que unirnos estar
juntos en solidaridad y mostrar que esto
es inaceptable y no es lo que sucedió es
horrible y no podemos dejarlo pasar un
profesor no fue libre para enseñar el
asesino de samuel para ti fue un joven
de 18 años presunto extremista
originario de chechenia antes de ser
asesinado para ti fue objeto de una
campaña airada en las redes sociales por
mostrar imágenes de profeta mahoma en
sus clases los manifestantes también
llevaron carteles de la publicación
satírica charlie hebdo haciendo el
paralelo de los ataques ocurridos en
francia en los últimos años puedes creer
que esto está pasando desde 2012
mohamed miradas charlando el teatro
bataclán y ahora los profesores
para esto como ella muchos ven el
asesinato de patti como otro ataque a la
república y a sus valores ellos atacaron
las instalaciones de charlie hebdo hace
unos años y ahora van tras el sistema de
educación para mí la escuela debe ser
secular y garantizar los valores de la
república francesa y de todos
un minuto de silencio y el himno
nacional un homenaje del pueblo francés
al profesor de historia asesinado por
enseñar la libertad de expresión
[Música]
hoy comenzamos una nueva serie sobre el
voto hispano en eeuu a dos semanas de
estas elecciones la comunidad latina es
la primera minoría en el país y un
número récord de votantes de esa
comunidad participarán en estos comicios
del 3 de noviembre convirtiéndose en un
electorado clave para las campañas del
presidente republicano donald trump y
también de su rival demócrata joe biden
que apelan al votante latino cuya
participación será decisiva en al menos
cinco estados en pendulares marina
sardenya nos ampliar el siguiente
informe
una campaña puerta a puerta con el
objetivo de atraer al electorado latino
a participar en los comicios del 3 de
noviembre el voto latino siempre fue
clave en las elecciones estadounidenses
pero este año los hispanos representan
la primera minoría étnica con 32
millones de votantes legibles el 13 3%
de la población total sin embargo la
participación entre la comunidad latina
ha sido tradicionalmente baja lucia
salinas quiere cambiar este rumbo nos ha
quitado lo de migración de está acá me
ha quitado el tps eso es mucha historia
y yo creo que ahorita muchas de nuestras
comunidades personas que somos
inmigrantes hijos de inmigrantes que
estoy pueden votar que hay muchos
jóvenes que están molestos de eso no
todos los hispanos tienen el privilegio
de votar hay al menos 11 millones de
migrantes indocumentados en el país el
estatus migratorio de maria jose le
niega el derecho al voto pero no le
impide movilizarse y hacer campaña en su
comunidad no puedo votar pero también
podemos puedo yo meter mi granito verdad
estar aquí buscando por abogando por una
candidata que nos tome en cuenta y le
importa la verdad importa' del vino de
nuestro bienestar y más específico y no
para la gente indocumentada
históricamente los hispanos se han
identificado con los demócratas
joe biden sigue liderando los sondeos
con un 67% frente al 24% del presidente
donald trump pero el voto latino no es
homogéneo y podría ser decisivo en esta
2 pendulares como florida arizona o
pensilvania por ello ambos candidatos
apelan a su voto crucial si hemos
logrado más para los hispanoamericanos
en 47 meses de lo que yo baiden ha
logrado en 47 años vamos a estar en una
situación en la que no podemos hacer
esto no podemos hacerlo sin todos
ustedes no podemos ganar sin la
comunidad de la economía la atención
médica y la gestión de la pandemia son
los principales temas para los latinos
en estos
y de esta manera llegamos al final del
informativo continúe con nosotros su
buen día para todos
[Música]
france24 en español